a policeman saw a drunk man looking for
something under a streetlight and asked
it the drunk what he lost the drunk says
I lost my keys and they both look
together under the streetlight after a
while the policeman asks are you sure
you lost them here the drunk replies no
I lost them in the park the policeman
says why are you searching here the
drunk replies this is where the light is
for decades this search strategy is
employed both by drunks and neutrino
hunters with no keys in sight and a few
key insights in 1916 Einstein published
the second of his general relativity
papers 100 years later using Einsteins
predictions we are at the precipice of
weighing the last elementary particle
whose mass is unknown is in this old
news don't we know all the fundamental
fundamental particle masses already
after the measuring the higgs boson mass
well yes and no looking at the standard
model we see 16 massive particles quarks
leptons like electrons and bosons such
as the photon plus the Higgs boson
charted together in a table reminiscent
of men do lives periodic table of the
elements except in the case of quarks
bosons and leptons on the table there is
no periodicity no apparent ordering at
work three of the six leptons which
means small and Greek particles that
don't participate in the strong nuclear
force are the three generations of
neutrinos electron muon and tau
neutrinos as integral as they are to the
foundations of matter we are in the dark
about their masses are particles mass is
arguably its most distinctive property
so this lacunae is rightfully seen as an
embarrassment for physics that is about
to change
neutrinos changed their flavor their
generation type from one flavor to
another as they sail through the cosmos
this is phenomenon is known as
oscillation the 2015 Nobel Prize in
Physics went to ty iki cajeta and Arthur
B McDonald for the discovery of neutrino
oscillations which shows that neutrinos
have mass their work devastatingly
refutes the claims presented in John
Updike's poem cosmic gall sorry John
while they remain small neutrinos do
have a mass after all thanks to cajeta
and McDonald not only do we know the
neutrinos have masked their work gives
us a lower limit on their masses at
least one of the three neutrinos must
have a mass bigger than about one
twentieth of an electron volt
physicists use Einsteins relationship
equals mc-squared to convert masses to
equivalent energies this is quite felt
the next heaviest elementary particle is
the electron whose mass is 10 million
times larger most importantly these
lower limits give a neutrino masses give
experimentalist thresholds to target all
that's left is to build a scale
sensitive enough to weigh them neutrinos
are generated in nuclear reactions such
as fusion and radioactive decay the
ultimate reactor of course was the
biggest cauldron of them all the Big
Bang like light neutrons are stable
their lifetimes are infinite because
like light there is nothing for them to
decay into since it's impossible to
collect enough neutrinos to weigh them
in a terrestrial laboratory cosmologists
will use massive galaxy clusters as
their scales sprinkled amidst the
luminous matter and the clusters are
innumerable neutrinos their masses can
be measured using gravitational lensing
a direct consequence of Einstein's
general theory of relativity all matter
dark and luminous gravitationally
deflects light gravitational lensing
effect rearranges photon trajectories as
Eddington showed during the famous 1919
total solar eclipse star positions were
displaced from where they should have
been in the sun's absence due to the
sun's warping of space-time the light
that should have been there was lens the
amount of movement the lensing
deflection angle told us the mass of the
lens what kind of light should we use to
weigh poltergeist particles like
neutrinos there certainly aren't enough
neutrinos in our solar system to bend
the sun's light the most promising light
source of all is also the oldest and
most abundant light in the universe the
three kelvin microwave background these
cosmic photons arose in the same ancient
cauldron that produced the neutrinos
plying the universe today the CMB is
cosmic wallpaper a background against
the background against which the mass of
all matter in the foreground galaxy
clusters including neutrinos can be
measured in 2015 the Planck satellite
showed the powerful evidence of
gravitational lensing of the CMB
using a technique that has eventually
guaranteed to detect neutrino masses
this technique based on CMB polarization
properties will dramatically improve in
2016 and beyond thanks to a suite of
experiments deploying tens of thousands
of detector
is cooled below 0.3 Kelvin at the South
Pole and in the Chilean Atacama Desert
neutrinos are also the very paradigm of
dark matter they're massive they're dark
that is they only interact with light
via gravity and they're neutral all
required properties of dark matter well
we know that neutrinos are not the
dominant form of the cosmos is missing
mass they are the only known form of
dark matter
after we measured their masses we will
use these neutrinos to thin the herd of
potential dark matter candidates just as
there are many different types of
ordinary matter ranging from quarks to
atoms we may expect that there are also
several kinds of dark matter perhaps
there is a dark periodic table the hunt
is on to directly detect dark matter and
several exciting upgrades to liquid
noble gas experiments are coming online
in 2016 and beyond perhaps there will be
detections but so far the direct
detection experiments have only produced
upper limits in the end neutrinos just
might be the only form of dark matter we
ever get to see the next century of
general relativity promises to be as
exciting as the first space time tells
matter how to move matter tells
space-time how to curve said John
Archibald wheeler we've seen what the
curvature is now we just need to find
out what's the matter and where better
to look for lost matter than where the
dark is